welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Catherine pantera brick a medical
anthropologist trained in human biology
and the social sciences she directs the
program on conflict resilience and
health at the Macmillan Center to engage
with academics practitioners and
policymakers who promote innovations in
global health together with faculty at
Yale UNICEF and other global partners
she works with the early childhood peace
consortium to disseminate scientific
knowledge on peacebuilding and violence
prevention professor Panter brick has
directed more than 40 interdisciplinary
projects worldwide has written many
scientific articles and co-edited seven
books including pathways to peace today
we'll talk with Professor Panther brick
about her new book medical
humanitarianism ethnographies of
practice welcome professor Panther brick
thank you for having me certainly let's
begin with your book please give us an
overview of it so the book medical
humanitarianism is presents 12 case
studies of humanitarian life and its
frame with an introduction in the
conclusion that shows the purpose on the
scope of the book and the purpose of the
book is to give concrete insights into
the practice of medical humanitarianism
and is directed to to audiences social
scientists and humanitarian
practitioners and I think the readers of
the book would be those who are curious
about the intersection of medicine human
rights advocacy international
development peace building and
humanitarianism and also be readers who
are interested in the power of
ethnography which is the systematic
study of people and culture in this case
of humanity of life as told through the
story for the main point of the book is
to 12 very powerful stories about
humanitarian life
all right we'll get to those 12 stories
in a minute but I think some of us don't
know what the term medical
humanitarianism means so tell us a
little bit about what that term means
the term is defined as the biomedical
Global Health epidemiological
initiatives undertaken to save lives or
alleviate suffering in crises born of
conflict as I still neglect so there's
three piece of that definition is about
health it's about intervention and it's
about crises and that's the gist of it
why we focus on medical humanitarianism
in particular is interesting the
humanitarian is about the practice of
care for people who are in great danger
or distress and medicine is about
clinical practice and knowledge
regarding health with humanitarian
aspirations so the two terms talk to
each other and it's true to say that
humanitarianism has become increasingly
professionalized and increasingly
medicalized so that why that's why it
existed a subfield okay may I say also
that other medical humanitarians is
really a field of practice is about the
people who practice humanitarian aid the
who deliver the aid and also the
policymakers that organized a local and
international delivery of aid and it's
also about a space of academic inquiry
about the cultures and the systems that
boost this humanitarian action so a lot
of books and articles have already been
written with a fairly critical I about
the moral and the ethical dilemmas and
the challenges and the unintended
consequences of humanitarian action so
it's both a field of practice and a
field of academic inquiry okay very good
so how did the book come about so I
wanted a book that would be great a
great book for teaching in anthropology
in the Jackson Institute of global
affairs okay I wanted a book that would
speak to the practice on the ground had
real experience I went to the book that
wasn't sensational journalism no
heavy jargon theory i went to the book
that would expand the intellectual
inquiry but be very compassionate to the
people who are taking very difficult
decisions in very frightened
environments because it's very easy to
be critical and alienate humanitarian
workers in difficult situations but you
also have to be you know compassionate
to the situation on the ground and I
felt or my co-editor family Sharon
Abramovich who wanted also to redefine
the field together we had a workshop in
the University of Florida where she is
and the University at Yale we invited
people who had stories to tell he could
write short memorable jargon-free
stories that would speak about that
would invite social critique but also we
would capture the moment the frat moment
of a humanitarian challenge and we then
decided to frame the book in this
comparative way of presenting the
12-story side-by-side to juxtapose them
so that the reader would be taken in by
the depth of the case study but also see
the breadth of the themes that would
arrive so in my metaphor it's like
having the reader go through the word
and seeing as much as the forest as it
does as he or she does from an
individual tree to really understand a
case study but understand the bigger
themes that arise okay and would you say
that these twelve stories are best case
practices exemplified or do you also
show some things that maybe they could
have done something a little bit better
now I think there there's no best
approach they really show conflict okay
real big dilemmas tough situations and
either because of a humanitarian worker
working in a particular situation or the
very difficult decisions that you can
make for instance withdrawing from a
country in conflict so they they're all
about a particular story of a particular
people in a moment of great difficulties
and they eliminate that situation okay
let's get to the meat of it pick one of
the stories and tell us about it you
know I'm also
interested in learning about the
contributors and of course the lessons
learned so if you can pick one of the
stories and and go through it and then
and tell us what the levy when we talk
about lessons learned I'll talk about
some other okay so I open up with
chapter one that I wrote with a
consultant who works for a local
government and an NGO on the
afghan-pakistan border areas and it
opens up with this this head of the
non-governmental organization that talks
about the killing of that just happened
on the on the on the road on those
border areas where a van that was
transporting NGO workers was overtaken
by a motorcycle the two riders pulled
out a five year old child and sprayed
with the van with bullet killing one man
and six women and they were all humanity
they were all employed by the local
government to to distribute humanitarian
aid so it continues with some of the
testimonies not not around this
particular taste but several test
millions of people working in
humanitarian settings in those fraught
borders caught in the Fox of conflict
and it really shows the moral experience
that happens for these local workers and
how they are kind of facing every day
the threat of kidnapping the threat of
killings the first of social ostracism
very difficult situation and how they
articulate their calling and it makes
for a chapter that focuses on human
dignity and compassion rather than
chapter that focuses only on suffering
and fear and then it continues on to
understand what the organization
themselves can provide for these workers
and we're familiar with these symptoms
of burnout where you get basic burnt out
by this humanitarian activity and what
people do is to alleviate fear to
alleviate distress and to find some kind
of calmness in their lives so that's the
example of a moment that's both in the
news we've had in the news recently two
bombings of MSF clinics so it
illustrates the
of life and and the chapters called
dignity under extreme duress it's an
extreme duress extreme danger situation
but it shows a spirit of human dignity
in articulating why you would want to
continue with that work right very good
um what about another of the
contributors tell us about another I
could tell you of many different ones
I'll probably give you two vignettes one
of them I'm sorry to interrupt so these
are from countries all over the world
yes yes there are many in Africa in Asia
Caribbean and Middle East yes that's
right now I of course yes okay the
Middle East one is Israel okay so give
us another example what another example
from Israel would be the balancing act
that humanitarian workers have to do
when they disperse medical aid to
Israeli citizens but also find
themselves wanting to disperse medical
aids to illegal migrants so you have
constantly to navigate a system whereby
some are more deserving than others so
it shows the ethical and moral dilemmas
of that another interesting chapter is
about the doctors working for the
British Army in Iraq and Afghanistan who
are doctors who therefore process
professor save lives but will also take
a life in allegiance to the military so
it's about these contested ideals that
you carry as a humanitarian worker in a
specific situation right okay the
trade-offs that you make right right so
it must be very difficult for people who
work out in the field do you talk at all
in the book about what a worker can do
to try and stay positive about what
they're doing if we have a whole section
on that moral experience and
understanding that in a deep way
we have the books that the other
chapters those stories that they're much
more critical very critical for instance
one by Tim Allen on the refugee camps in
Uganda their shows that humanitarian
workers are really working within
bubbles bubbles of knowledge they they
have camps themselves adult they only
interact during the day they don't see
what's going on during the night they
have their own idea of what is going on
and what the reality is and what disease
are afflicting people and so there's
this dissonance between what's really
happening on the ground and the
humanitarian knowledge so it's a
deconstruction of knowledge and that
chapter is particularly critical for
instance so I would imagine when you're
teaching about this this is something
you can highlight and say here's you
know suggest ways to get around that or
improve upon it I mean how would you
teach to that particular example so the
point of the book i think is to let the
story speak for itself so in the example
i gave you about the afghan-pakistan
border i think i try to make the story
as compassionate as possible in a story
gave you about the Ugandan refugee camps
the stories as critical as possible I
try to steer a middle ground between
being critical and compassionate I want
an insight about the humanitarian field
that is both I don't want to invite so
much criticas to be invite paralysis
about having no action happen or the eye
of humanitarian workers I don't want to
be such a you know have such an impulse
of heroism and humanitarian action that
have no critical reflection about what
I'm doing so it's a balancing act but we
don't say much except an introduction
and conclusion we let the story speak
for themselves and the idea is that you
will just come out with this idea yes of
course it's difficult but that's not
news but they are specific areas to
focus on in which you can be much more
have much more robust understanding of
the situation on the ground right okay
so in terms of conclusions you know what
what do you offer so adolescence or the
conclusion well let's do lessons I'm
sorry so the lessons
I think I take away the lessons as
understand there's four things that I
would want to teach about about medical
humanitarianism one of them is about the
grounding of that experience what it's
like on in the minute of humanitarian
and what it means and how complex it can
be and how human the stories are another
one is about this knowledge this idea of
knowledge that we construct so we are
for instance in the situation of crisis
let's say one of the chapters of the
book talks about nisha and the food
crisis now do you define this as a
medical crisis like MSF médecins all
Fonterra Doctors Without Borders is
doing which means a medical and
nutritional intervention or you define
that as a livelihood crisis in which
case you need food security and
international development so the way you
call that crisis is contested and that
means the solutions that follow are very
dependent on that that knowledge another
Alex travail for instance asks us to
understand patterns of violence lethal
violence whether they're genocide or
civil war or ethnic strife the word you
give to that crisis the emerge whether
you take say it's an emergency or not
defines the solution so that the body of
knowledge is actually very contested and
a lot of it is about the power of the
person who speaks so local voices are
ignored expert voices are called for one
of the lessons that I've learned is that
we've often focus on the suffering of
the beneficiaries and the safety of
international expatriates workers that
we've sidelined these national
humanitarian workers that work all their
lives in one place I've learned that
that knowledge is very contested I've
learned more about the ethical
challenges that happen one chapter in
the book is about a small NGO in Sierra
Leone that accepts students from Western
institutions that come for short term
humanitarian missions and all the
problematic flexible ethical events that
happen in that wake with a lot of
movement and try
movement so everybody gets to be a
humanitarian in that sense so it's a
very fluid and very contested kind of
field that's why it makes you think and
the picture of the book is about shows
both the emotion of suffering and the
critical thinking that you need to do so
I like the subtitle ethnographies of
practice it's about practice but it's
about through telling a story that you
understand those lessons that they speak
to you so it's the stories or the
lessons I go is that you can go from the
very deeply personal story to a very
political story and back again and that
tells you about the human and the social
side of humanity general life and it
seems like it's extremely complicated
it's complicated but that doesn't
involve that doesn't invite paralysis by
either the very wonderful thing
happening is that dial or that
conversation happening between academics
and practitioners we have some examples
of this at Yale so you know humanitarian
sounds paralyzed by complication they
have a mandate it's how you define your
mandate it allows you to act but I think
it's important that they understand that
they're it is kind of complicated in how
you approach so I think those the
humanitarian actors are the ones who
understand the best about the complexity
of their case but in the end it is a
humanitarian purpose in the end it's an
act of caregiving is sort not an act of
saving lives but an act of caring for
humanity so that's medical practice in
essence but everybody everybody involved
in the field knows it's complicated the
main thing is to learn about lessons
learned of course as I said before the
the field is in question increasingly
professionalized so we teach about this
we train people about this we're trained
in the field through long-term
experience you you learn on on the job
so to speak and then you come out with
sometimes huge respect for the people
who are
living in danger doing an imperfect job
of being there where it counts so I come
out with the other side not throwing my
hands in the air but with immense
respect really with what is happening on
the ground for many of the stories there
some obviously which are not so noble
and others which are very much so right
right and conclusions so in conclusion
as well as speaking as an anthropologist
i would say that what I taken out is
that I need more fluency in the
languages of humanitarian life and by
that I don't mean learning speak
learning English and French or any other
languages I mean the technical language
of delivery of care the administrative
language of organizing international
assistance the financial language of the
flows of money that govern action the
medical language about the intervention
that happened so I become much more
multi-dimensional in my understanding of
humanitarian practice and I think that
moves a feel for word so you you build
like Russian dolls you build a financial
administrative medical and technical
aspect of humanitarian assistance and I
think also you learn to be very
respectful of the practical concerns of
humanitarian assistance which is
delivering aid where it needs to be done
on delivering assistance where it needs
to be done and very also casting the
practice of humanitarian assistance with
with some critical some giving offering
some critical insights about it so the
to really go together it's a dance of I
will say you know and understanding
insights that give you a critical and
compassionate understanding of the
practice of humanitarian assistance very
good thank you so much for being here
today and sharing your work Thank You
Merlin it's a pleasure to be here thank
you for more information about professor
Panter brick and her research please
visit our website at macmillan report
yale edu be sure to join us again for
another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale